foreign
[Music]
if you were to ask anyone what the
prominent genre of anime was in the past
few years I bet you'll get a number of
isakai answers the thing was everywhere
and I mean everywhere right around the
tail end of the last decade from what I
can see though the train has slowed down
if just by the tiniest bit in the past
couple of years while the forgettable
seasonal still existed the genre
continued to churn out Banger after
Banger and today's list will be
featuring 10 of my favorite action
issakai to first come out over the span
of the past three years
kicking things off is combatants will be
dispatched
drop it off
quite a knee show to start everything
off combatants will be dispatched is a
quirky is a kind that is the other
creation of the guy who brought us
konosuba and his talent simply showed
here that we once again got a goofball
of a show that gave me the same Vibes as
his previous work while also feeling a
little bit different combatants will be
dispatched likewise Revels in the comedy
the crazy goofiness of it all there's
lots of laughs to be had and while an
overarching plot of defeating a Demon
Lord this time as a leader of an evil
Corporation does exist we all know
people came for the jokes as expected of
something from the konosuba author
expect a lot of running gags innuendos
and misunderstandings fueling the comedy
plus a lot of wild reaction is certainly
not the type of show you immediately
recommend to someone not yet accustomed
to this side of anime but if it's the
type who absolutely loves these kind of
goofy shows that don't take themselves
seriously and give this one a try
[Music]
to continue our track into the world of
2020's izakai we proceed to skeleton
night in another world
[Music]
skeletonite an interesting case at least
from a very personal perspective after
all it's a show that I didn't exactly
put into my priority list when the
season aired then I heard the cool
opening and decided to roll with it kind
of like how the main characters in this
story does finding out that you've woken
up in a game World screw trying to
escape and just roll with the new life
you have skeleton night if I were to
rank it amongst the isakai from the past
three years is simply adequate it has
its moments and I did enjoy following
ark's journey in this new world there's
some neat fights and characters that
while not exactly memorable do add some
spice to the show normally I'd call it
an isakai that plays safe but still has
a charm to it making it a bit better
than average however it does have some
content which definitely doesn't make it
too safe to recommend to people who are
still trying to learn the ropes of
watching anime much like the previous
title
before we continue this video have you
ever thought how awesome it would be to
live and fight in the world of one of
your favorite anime well look no further
because we're here to introduce to you
Code Geass Lelouch of the Rebellion lost
stories it's a live 2D video game that
brings the world of Code Geass to you
Code Geass Lelouch of the Rebellion lost
stories perfectly captures the complex
world of the original series we all know
what happened because we followed
Lelouch every step of the way but the
game offers a fresh and completely
different route on how the story of Code
Geass is told instead of following the
loot we get to see the unique POV as the
protagonist however we don't have only
new characters but we have the entire
cast of the series along with their
original voice actors as well so you
know the dub has the best quality and it
doesn't stop there either the graphics
and art follow the original Code Geass
style immersing you more into the series
world the gameplay mechanics made me
think about every move I'll take so it's
perfect for people who love strategy
games and best of all the 3D animated
mix and the combat effects were some of
the most eye-catching I've seen in any
given anime download Code Geass Lelouch
of the Rebellion lost stories now using
my link and you might even see the
swimsuit version of the game in the
future also comment down below which is
your favorite character in the game now
back to the video how a realist hero
rebuilt the kingdom is at number eight
if there's one thing to give realist
hero credit for it's how it decides to
be Innovative for a change it tries
something different in that its premise
revolves around a hero not going on an
adventure to defeat some Demon Lord but
instead trying to solve a kingdom from
its woes from within instead of an
action RPG think of something more like
the strategy games or Resource
Management games you've seen or heard of
it was a great idea even if the
execution can leave more to be desired
in some areas I mean it's a one-core
adaptation of a light novel so that's
inevitable still I like how the
relationship and asset management
aspects take the fall from it's still
got some action at its core but the show
really feels like a breath of fresh air
from the typical issakai fair in a way
it reminded me of Alder ramen in the sky
another underrated show try this one out
if you want to break from all those
Fantastic Adventures or fast-paced
fighting
okay
[Music]
next up is the relative newcomer dead
Mount death play
yeah
something that just came out a few
months ago dead Mount death play has
already shot its way to my favorite
isakai titles from the past three years
a reverse isakai that revolves around
the powerful Necromancer corpse God and
his new life in modern Tokyo all while
he tries to navigate and survive the
underbelly of human society in his deep
powered State sounds pretty cool that's
doubly true if you're someone fond of
durarara which the show strongly reminds
me of and like the former dead Mount
death play is a show that truly excels
in World building it's pretty obvious
that the approach was to not focus as
much on the straightforward overarching
plot but on the interconnected plot
lines and how they tie to each other
different doesn't always mean good if
you're to ask me but dead Mountain death
play does the whole interconnected plot
lines thing in such an engaging way that
I just can't help but praise him it's
got the dark backdrop that many people
also adore and it's filled to the brim
with Mysteries that you slowly pick up
as you watch the show with extra
attention next we have so I'm a spider
so what
[Music]
so I'm a spider so what follows the
tried and true formula of the main
character being transported into another
world as a lowly creature hey it worked
for slime splendidly in fact and this
spider isakai show turned out pretty
alright too this time we have gumoko
being reincarnated into a spider who has
the ability to get stronger with each
victory in this incredibly dangerous
fantasy world it's a show that provides
a safe space for people who already love
this kind of show along with the RPG
mechanics and while the show is overall
nothing too notable or unique it does
what it needs to do competently enough
now to address the elephant in the room
the show is rendered with CG and that
might put some people off I do think
that it's not too bad even if things can
get clunky at times I still feel that
the show has a lot of good points that
allow it to shine in spite of the
troubles it may face pretty reminiscent
of our plaque protagonist I have to say
summer
[Music]
and why don't you hit that like button
up there to show your support for the
video it helps the video do well and
makes a massive difference thanks guys
reincarnated as a sword is the next
anime on the list
[Music]
foreign
how about taking it a step further from
being reincarnated as a spider how about
becoming a sentient sword the very sword
that may be the key to cat girlfriend's
fight for freedom and a rise to the top
reincarnated as a sword is one of the
better issakai titles in the past few
years in my opinion it's not as much of
a complete package or a standout as some
of the other titles we'll be getting
later on the list it's easy for a show
like this to get lost in the shuffle of
the busy seasonal cycle with a plot
that's not exactly unique or lacking the
controversy to keep people talking but
hey it works and it works very well
reincarnated as a sword for me became
one of the more enjoyable modern isekai
thanks to his lovable characters the
chemistry is there between the two main
characters and the dynamic between them
is engaging enough to carry the show for
the most part the plot and setting may
seem pretty generic with a Twist here or
there but this show proves that you
don't exactly need to be unique to be
enjoyable and for a lot of anime watches
that's more than enough
now we're at the doorstep of the top
three and our last entry before top
three is tsukimichi
a prospective hero gets reincarnated
into a fantasy world but quickly finds
himself the object of scorn rejected by
all of mankind the powerful hero begins
his journey to the top with a band of
trustworthy allies from non-human races
the Plucky teammates will be there to
help the hero reach his desires and
perhaps find a way to fix Society in the
process sounds familiar but what if we
Infuse it with an over-the-top parody
aspect as well as some great world
building and a bit of dark elements then
you get tsukimichi what I appreciate
about tsukimichi is that it establishes
its identity quite early and while it
does have its share of dark elements it
balances the light-heartedness with the
serious plot lines well it's definitely
not a show that has the same cynical
point of view as something like Shield
hero it's not too often that we see
parodies in the world of isakai at least
relative to the number of shows in the
genre we've had across the years maybe
that's why when one rolls around like
gonusuba and another title we'll be
taking a look at later it comes off as
very notable and attention-catching it's
also pretty cool that we have this title
on the same list as combatants will be
dispatched they're not exactly too
similar but they have the same Vibes
with tsukimichi having a bit less lewd
humor even if the type of Comedy is the
same across both titles
foreign
but it's time to temporarily leave the
world of light-hearted parody because
the rank 3 title is no laughing matter
its world's finest assassin
[Music]
world's finest assassin provides a much
wanted Edge to the world of isakai we've
seen a lot of isakai shows where some
need gets reincarnated into the hero of
Destiny looking to free the world of the
terror of the Demon Lord but how about a
grizzled no-nonsense assassin being
tasked to take out another hero gone
Rogue now we're talking while it has the
more mature feel for an isakai it's
still got the tropes to make Veterans of
the genre uncomfortable you've still got
the overpowered hero and the Harem for
the approach in using these elements
does feel more complete there's a
genuine bond between Luke and the girls
and I enjoyed how the show didn't just
end up going the whole using people as
tools path that we've come to expect out
of a premise like this with this being
from the guy who gave us redo of healer
we can clearly see the Creator's talent
in writing material on both sides of the
spectrum as the two are simply night and
day in terms of writing styles and
atmosphere I think that the main thing
that holds world's finest assassin is
that it's too short 12 episodes isn't
long enough for us to explore more of
the world and the characters especially
the goddess character who seems a lot
more manipulative and cunning than we
actually get the chance to see
for our second Placer it's time for
Eminence in Shadow
[Music]
we've already featured a handful of
parody issakai titles on the list but
none of them have come close to Eminence
in Shadow in terms of popularity and
that's somewhat expected the subverting
expectations with the protagonist's goal
plays a part in it but I personally
think more the popularity comes from how
loud and proud Eminence in Shadow is
with what it's trying to do after all
none of them do the parody aspect in
such an apologetic manner quite like
Eminence and Shadow does and that has
led to one of the more memorable and
refreshing protagonists in Sid who
carries the traits of an overpowered
hero but remains completely dense with
his chuney Antics and how cool he wants
to be we've seen a lot of unwilling
wavering protagonists of dark Edge Lord
protagonists the Sid in reality is
neither of those in spite of him wanting
to show everyone he's the latter the
other characters all have their personal
charms and quirks and they all come
together to form a very memorable group
that sort of antics that are genuinely
enjoyable to watch there's the presence
of actual drama and character moments in
the show but those elements remain
subtle and meld pretty well into the
more visible more trending audacious
moment moments like the I am Atomic
scene overall if you're looking for
something that's unapologetically wild
in the world of isakai parodies Eminence
in Shadow deserves your attention
[Music]
finishing up the list is none other than
mushoku tensei
mushoku tensei is a pioneer of the genre
in quite the literal sense a lot of the
elements that we see in issakai were
largely influenced by this show and man
this show does them really really well
it helps at the production values for
the title are Top Notch and you can
really feel the love and care the anime
team had in making this anime I mean
when you've got a studio dedicated to
keep churning out season after season of
one of the Legends in the novel World
they better make sure they do a damn
good job at it unfortunately we also
can't talk about mushoku tensei without
mentioning some of its more questionable
elements that made it a contender for
the most controversial anime the past
few years it's definitely not a show for
everyone and it brazenly crosses lines
other anime won't even dare to step
close to I personally don't have too
strong of an opinion on things but
simply consider this a precaution on the
sexual content in case you want to pick
up this show getting past that however
and what you've got is probably the most
complete isakai title with some great
world building memorable fights
character drama and an alarm plot filled
with growth and adventure and the best
thing about it it looks like something
that could be primed for a full
adaptation meaning we're likely to get
to see the full story of rudius told in
anime form
that pretty much makes up my list of my
best action isakai anime from the past
three years what does yours look like
make sure to give your favorites a shout
out in the comments section and tell
everyone about them thanks for watching
and I hope that I managed to either
feature your favorite action isakai or
got you something new to watch have a
good day and I'll see you next time